who would win in a rap battle between
drake and g-eazy
what's up gq i'm g eazy and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
let's check twitter serious question
is g eazy pronounced separately or like
jeezy it's actually g eazy
it is g-eazy i didn't like my name when
i was little so i went by my
initials ge and i just became g-eazy my
question is
why the sudden decision to sing in your
recent songs digging it by the way
quarantine man honestly i was playing my
piano a lot
and i've always wanted to learn how to
sing and i'm still learning
i'm still pretty bad at it i've been
rapping for about 17 years
so you know i'm i'm comfortable and
confident
with that approach you know but
trying to sing and do something for the
first time and put yourself out there is
wow scary edgy easy
what was it like the first time you
heard e40s first on far along
that had to be nuts it was insane e40 is
a voice that i grew up listening to
he's you know an icon a legend a king
you know one of the biggest artists ever
out of the bay area when
we did our first song together and i got
the vocals back i was actually on tour
i was on the bus and i ran and i plugged
my phone in and i listened to it and i
lost my mind just hearing his voice on
my song was crazy
shouts out 40. who are your favorite
artists outside of the rap genre
i listen to a lot of jazz dizzy
gillespie chet baker
miles davis nina simone i'm outside of
jazz
cage the elephant's probably my favorite
band i don't know a lot of stuff man i
listen to a lot of music
some random guy hit me impersonating you
super weird i know so my question is how
many confirmed catfish
do you have out there acting like you
and have you ever caught them up
i'm interested you know that's a weird
thing
i i can't imagine what would bring
somebody to do that there's this really
weird account though
on instagram just been following a lot
of my friends
called young gerald's legs and they just
post pictures of my legs
so shout out young gerald's legs i don't
know if they're trying to impersonate my
legs and act like they are my legs but
if you're out there trying to beat young
gerald's legs man i only got two of them
and they're right here
these are the real ones how'd you say
cora i wasn't even familiar with this
i feel like a grandpa is saying that but
all right quora
why is jesus often referring to his
zodiac sign and his music
because i'm a gemini and i like the way
the word
sounds and duality and juxtaposition
and polarizing two sides
and dr jekyll and mr hyde you know the
irony is i know i talk about it in my
music a lot but i'm really not
you know very into like zodiacs and
horoscopes and all that sometimes when
you read a horoscope you're like damn
that really is true but could it be true
for anybody kinda
you know you can't believe what you what
you want to believe so maybe i don't
know man
i just know i'm a gemini does ged have
any protest songs
i wrote a song called love is gone where
i speak up about a lot of stuff that's
been going on in our world
you know i think it's it's to a certain
extent everybody's civic duty to
be a part of the conversation and speak
up and you know be active in times like
these especially
you know as an entertainer you're not
necessarily a politician or an activist
you know but again it's like it's you
know a certain part of your
responsibility and what you do with your
platform
what is the real name of the rapper
g-eazy my real name is
gerald earl gillum
my friends my family uh
they call me either gerald jerry
or g or mr easy
who would win in a rap battle between
drake and g-eazy
me know i don't know man
i i love battle rap as a sport i used to
watch a lot of like smack dvds and stuff
like that
and i know drake is cuffed from that
cloth too i've known drake a long time
huge huge huge fan of his music but i
beat him in a battle
is g easy an underrated rapper hell yeah
i'm underrated
all right let's see some youtube
comments
g eazy really the 5.0 version at eminem
changed my mind
i think comparisons are just an inherent
part of
being a you know musician an entertainer
a public figure whatever you want to
call it it just what comes with the
territory so it's like
you got to learn to tune out a lot of it
it is what it is though
you know it doesn't really bother me
it's like you know you're talking about
one of the highest selling artists of
all time and one of the greatest rappers
of all
all time so you know i'm still on my way
i'm trying to make my mark
i'm the 5.0 version of young gerald i
read a
post office charles bukowski i'm reading
a farewell to arms right now
ernest hemingway does he really read the
books
just curious it often like surprises
people
that i read i hated reading actually
growing up
and in school and i guess maybe it
wasn't until a couple years ago
that i just i i don't know i just
started appreciating reading
i was a huge fan of steve jobs his
biography
had a big impact on me that might have
started it but i also like fiction i
mean i
i love classic literature like old
hemingway and fitzgerald
charles bukowski is probably my favorite
author so yes
i do actually read the books instagram
how is your skin so clear
i don't know man i wash my face every
morning
shout out to my mom she has great skin
and i'm just i'm just lucky to be her
son
nah i mean i wash my face put on some
moisturizer step out the house
i never wear sunscreen i probably should
but look at me
okay ladies and gentlemen the the that's
all folks
i'm signing off the internet the best
whoever did it and got away with it
[Music]